[Musique]
ici pas de racisme
noirs blancs juifs non juifs musulmans
non musulmans nous sommes tous sur le
même pied de fraternité si vous n'avez
pas l'exploitation de l'homme par
l'homme
[Musique]
à
la paix
et
appartient à toute l'humanité dans son
enfant
[Musique]
où
j'ai trouvé ici l'endroit où on pouvait
réellement s'exprimer en toute liberté
c'est le meilleur endroit pour élever un
enfant
je suis heureux ville depuis trois ans
et je cherche la vérité
je suis ici parce que je me suis senti
appelé
[Musique]
[Rires]
le travail que nous faisons nous le
faisons bénévolement et ce n'est pas
dans le but de gagner de l'argent ou
pour
ça titre et une hiérarchie c'est
simplement parce que le travail nous
plaît que nous le faisons
[Musique]
ah ah
il atteint cette espèce de fascination
de voir ce que ça va être quand ça va
être fini parce que en fin de compte
dont c'est parce qu'on est en train de
construire
[Musique]
où